Ese soy yo.
Después de graduarme, como la mayoría en Harvard,
decidí unirme a la productora WWE.
Ese también soy yo.
(Risas)
Seguro que me recuerdan del Monday Night Raw de 2002 a 2003.
Me lo pasé genial
jugando a ser lo que la gente le gusta llamar
Chris Harvard, el snob de la liga.
(Risas)
Era perfecto para mí.
Pero desafortunadamente,
fui golpeado en la cabeza por mi colega Bubba Ray Dudley,
y sufrí un traumatismo craneal severo.
Que derivó en lo que se convirtió en síntoma permanentes de postraumatismo:
constantes dolores de cabeza, insomnio, depresión, dificultad para pensar.
Y en este primer año,
traté de descifrar cómo hacer para que ese dolor desapareciera.
No lograba las respuestas que necesitaba de los médicos,
así que empecé a investigar documentación médica.
Y allí encontré todo este historial sobre traumatismos
de los que no nos habían hablado.
Decidí escribir un libro sobre ello,
llamado Head Games: Football's Concussion Crisis
que salió en 2006.
Pero en ese proceso, aprendí que no solo se trataba de traumatismos craneales.
Aprendí sobre una enfermedad llamada encefalopatía traumática crónica o ETC.
Llamada demencia pugilística por conocerse solo entre boxeadores.
Sabíamos que muchos golpes en la cabeza muchas veces entre boxeadores
podrían causar que el cerebro empezara a degenerar.
Y ellos tenían síntomas
como problemas de memoria, problemas cognitivos,
depresión, falta de control, agresividad.
Básicamente,
me lesionaron en el momento ideal,
cuando se estudió los dos primeros casos de jugadores de la NFL
y resultó que ambos tenían ETC.
El primero, Mike Webster, 50 años, ya tenía demencia.
El segundo, Terry Long, 45 años cuando se quitó la vida.
El examinador médico en Pittsburgh decidió mirar sus cerebros.
Y encontró esta enfermedad.
Escribí un capítulo sobre ella,
y pensé que la gente haría mucho revuelo.
Sorpresivamente, incluso con los dos primeros casos positivos
nunca se dio una noticia nacional sobre
lo que pasaba en el fútbol con los casos de ETC.
Así que el libro se publicó,
sin pena ni gloria,
hasta que un día leyendo el periódico, el 20 de noviembre de 2006,
descubrí que Andre Waters se había quitado la vida.
Aquellos que saben de futbol,
crecí viendo a Andre Waters.
El exdefensa de los Eagles de Philadelphia,
de 44 años, era entrenador de futbol de 2ª división
cuando decidó ponerse una pistola en su cabeza.
El artículo me recordó que su nick era Dirty Waters. (Agua sucia)
Era conocido por liderar con su cabeza.
Pensé en revisar
si alguna vez había hablado de los traumatismos craneales que tenía.
Y encontré una cita de 1994 donde decía,
"Paré de contar mis lesiones cerebrales a la 15ª.
No decía nada, olía sales aromáticas y volvería a salir."
Y me preguntaba si él había tenido ETC también.
Si eso habría contribuido a ese final escogido para su vida.
Llamé al médico que hizo los dos primeros estudios y le dije:
"Creo que debería estudiar a Andre Waters."
Y él dijo, "Me gustaría.
El problema es que, los dos primeros casos murieron en el condado
y pude estudiarlos como parte de mi trabajo.
No puedo con Andre Waters, él murió en Florida.
Si quieres estudiarlo, tendrás que descubrir
cómo conseguirme su cerebro."
Así que dije, "Bien.
¿cómo se consigue un cerebro?."
(Risas)
Me devané los sesos
y pensé, ¿por qué no llamo al médico forense
que creo que tiene el cerebro ahora?
Así que llamé al médico forense en Florida, y dije,
"No me conoce, ¿pero aún tiene el cerebro de Andre Waters?."
(Risas)
Y él dijo, "Sí, lo tengo"
Dije, "Bien, ¿va a examinar su posible ETC?."
Él dijo que no, de hecho, no creía que fuera una enfermedad real.
Dije, "Bien, ¿le importa si me lo quedo?."
Y él dijo, "Mire, joven,
no puedo darle el cerebro.
Necesita permiso de la familia
si es de un pariente cercano
se lo cederé."
Y dije, "¡Genial!"
Y me dí cuenta que tenía que descubrir quién era su familiar y preguntar
y resultó ser la madre de Waters, de 88 años.
Me senté allí, tomé el aliento y pensé,
"¿Voy a llamar fríamente a una madre en duelo de 88 años
quien acaba de perder a su hijo?."
Y gran parte de mí, dijo: "No lo hagas.
Es demasiada carga para esta mujer,
ella ya ha pasado por mucho."
Pero otra voz en mi cabeza dijo,
"¿Sabes qué?
Si la gente se mata por esta enfermedad
y pudiéramos estudiarla, quizás prevendría esto en el futuro,
a veces solo tienes que aguantar y hacer algo que es muy duro."
Así que la llamé.
Primero, nadie contestó
La segunda vez, sin respuesta, tercera...nada.
A la quinta, conseguí una respuesta.
Gracias a Dios, su familia fue cortés y dijeron
"Sabes, queremos saber qué le pasó a Andre.
Por qué cambió tanto en los últimos cinco años de vida."
Y así estudiamos el cerebro
y resultó que él tenía ETC.
Fue el tercer jugador de la NFL diagnosticado con esta enfermedad.
Así es como se ve.
Él estaba entre leve y severo.
Tenemos a los tres jugadores de la NFL aquí.
Quizás esto deba tratarse un poco más seriamente.
Quizás algo esté pasando aquí.
Así acabé creando la Concussion Legacy Foundation,
formalicé mi trabajo y todo,
así que ya no era el tipo llamando por cerebros.
Busqué por el mundo
y junté el mejor equipo de investigadores que pude encontrar.
Nos asociamos con la Universidad de Boston
con científicos de la VA en Boston,
e iniciamos un banco de cerebros.
Si quieres saber cómo curar enfermedades degenerativas,
hay que empezar estudiando cerebros.
En ese momento, éramos el primer centro del mundo centrado en ETC.
No había sido estudiado formalmente.
Empezamos el banco de cerebros, y es mi misión conseguir los cerebros
para la Dr. Ann McKee y su banco de cerebros, justo en el centro.
También trabajamos con el Dr.Bob Stern, Dr.Robert Cantu,
realmente un equipo de ensueño que apoyo.
Así mi trabajo es conseguir cerebros.
Y he sido muy exitoso en estos primeros años.
Desde 2007 he empezado cada día leyendo obituarios.
Y es una manera dura de vivir.
Es duro para mí
y es incluso peor para las pobres familias a las que he llamado
en los últimos 10 años para pedirles los cerebros.
Al principio del proceso, empezó a carcomerme.
Y pensé si podía encontrar otra forma
para que la gente donara sus cerebros a esta investigación.
Y pensé: ¿y si pudiéramos crear una cultura de
donación de cerebros en este país?
¿Si se volviera normal para los atletas donar sus cerebros tras morir?
De este modo empecé un registro de donación de cerebros.
Y empecé a preguntar a atletas
si prometerían públicamente donar sus cerebros a la ciencia.
Y empezó, de hecho, con un jugador de hockey en 2009.
Una de las primeras promesas era un exjugador de hockey de Harvard.
Noah Welch, quien estaba en la NHL por aquel entonces.
Fue un inicio lento que la gente comprendiera esto.
Cuando la noticia ocupó las portadas
"Noah Wlch promete donar su cerebro a la ciencia"
dijo que al ir al vestuario al día siguiente,
uno de los compañeros lo llevó a parte y dijo,
"He oído que estás donando tu cerebro a la ciencia."
Y él dijo, "Sep"
El otro dijo, "Guau, ¿cuántos partidos te vas a saltar?"
(Risas)
Historia verídica.
Pero hemos obtenido un éxito notable
más de 2500 atletas se han unido.
Han recibido una tarjeta de donante que guardan en su billetera.
Esta es mía, obviamente la primera, dice 01.
Y donaré mi cerebro a esto.
También hemos tenido suerte de tener gente como Brandi Chastain,
icono del futbol femenino,
Dale Earnhardt Jr. de la NASCAR
Hace dos semanas, Nick Buoniconti del Salón de la Fama
quien fue diagnosticado con demencia, se unió prometiendo su cerebro
Está siendo maravilloso, y lo grandioso de esto,
es que ha funcionado cambiando cómo conseguimos cerebros.
Ahora, en lugar de tener que llamarlos, más familias nos llaman
y el teléfono se descuelga solo.
Y así podemos centrarnos en recoger esta información
determinando cómo trabajamos hacia una cura,
como trabajamos hacia la prevención
y nuestra vida se volvió mucho más fácil.
Este es uno de los titulares que hemos tenido
de atletas prometiendo sus cerebros
El problema es lo que hemos aprendido.
Cuando empezamos,
solo existían 45 casos en el mundo de esta enfermedad
que fueron estudiados en bancos de cerebros.
Desde entonces, adquirimos 500 cerebros
y encontramos que 300 tenía ETC.
Poniéndolo en perspectiva,
el resto del mundo no ha estudiado 100 cerebros desde que comenzamos.
Lo que hemos visto es muy alarmante.
Algunos de Uds. puede que hayan visto el titular en julio
en el New York Times.
Y un reciente estudio que publicamos,
sobre los primeros 111 jugadores de la NFL que exploramos,
110 dieron positivo en esta enfermedad.
De los primeros 53 estudiantes de futbol universitarios,
48 dieron positivo.
Es algo que preocupa enormemente.
Y ahora, estoy muy centrado
en cómo podemos tratar ahora esta enfermedad.
Aún no se puede diagnosticar el ETC en personas vivas,
no tenemos tratamientos que vayan a salir
de la industria farmacéutica en los próximos cinco años.
Es una larga, larga lucha.
Pero la Concussion Legacy Foundation está aquí para no solo facilitarlo
es cuestión de tiempo,
pero por lo pronto, podemos prevenirlo.
Podemos prevenirlo
si paramos de golpear tanto a la gente en la cabeza.
Debemos parar de golpear a los niños en la cabeza.
Resulta que no es bueno golpear a un niño de 5 años en la cabeza
500 veces al año.
Ya que abre la puerta a esta enfermedad
Así tendremos media batalla ganada.
Pero tengo la gran esperanza de que estamos en camino de curarla.
Espero que comprendan mi historia un poco mejor.
Y ahora que hemos conseguido conocernos un poco mejor,
es hora de que les pregunte algo,
"¿Pueden darme su cerebro?"
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.